welcome to this video playing pop 129
this is Indonesia right no it's Poland
yeah I'm screwing this up all the time
they're very similar those flex but okay
the roccos in yeah I don't really have a
good line against that probably a.m.
this is quite the same for some top
players and the difference is that they
hacked they've actually tried to get an
advantage with some line which I cannot
claim the system this is the main line I
guess capture it's a bit early i think
okay i'm not an expert i can go back now
on to age 3 i mean i can take take take
it all right come on let's let's let's
go back let's go back I can try night if
no 95 it's not a good idea but maybe
just this on f3e form you cannot so
easily meow move the other night all
right now my g5 bishop is hanging okay
so f3 or night less 95 can be okay well
I need to attend this first year
hmm yeah that that didn't that didn't
work out really well now black gets the
night to d5 this does not look great I i
really need counterplay here badly yeah
I wasn't sure if this is really great
but maybe it is yeah at least he's
playing it absolutely immediately
sometimes those pawns can actually be a
weakness not not totally sure in this
case I will attack it yet another time
with Quincy one yeah I don't want the
Queen trait and my king is right near
the pond so if if he trades now I have
rugby one knocking I can use the King to
to control the pawn
one idea very attractive idea actually
its root B 1 B 5v5 maybe I should do
this immediately before something else
is happening be 5v5 and and it just
drops basically I just need to be
cautious that if it takes g takes this F
form so i probably should even prepare
it with g3 yeah g3 and then look B 5v5
wins the pond yeah after the Queen trade
this suddenly becomes a weakness I think
it's a very very common case where this
kind of advanced porn is a actually not
an advantage it certainly is so it's
very good in the middle game because
it's also an attacking and attacking
unit against White's king but I'm not
really sure here ruki 5 will come maybe
rookie 5 rook takes you five every five
f4 or something activating but it still
shouldn't be good for wide
hmm now should I take it I could play a
for first but okay here it's not not
worrying anymore before I will just take
you might play be five maybe I should
oops directly directly battle that I can
also go look a one here that goes before
I have the check yeah but rupee one is
probably better i am at the term just
keeps everything everything save look
be4 it's a bit per cell phone
yeah this should be ok before I can just
take with the rook
yeah g4 I guess oh it's now in some way
to to play this a bit more actively i
can actually actually I can play this
one threatening rook a6 with checkmate
look a 66 made if it takes on g3 that's
really look a 6cm forcing him to play
rook the aid and then I can then I can
recapture ng3
it also look b6 now threatened it takes
before I take every place before I take
it King be for Ruby six and the past
pants will promote yahoo could be six
round just winning the pawn check check
um go to is seven yeah maybe just
directly pushing the pawn should be
right check time warning yeah i have i
have two of them
hmm okay
it's as easy as probably just just
keeping it protected on your 7 ya know I
can take him black resign yeah that was
an interesting and interesting strategic
feature this pawn I mean right here my
my opening is certainly not great yeah
this is clear and this is this is a
debatable decision but it's interesting
here what I absolutely do believe after
the Queen trade I'm fine this is this is
I think very clear and this this is the
idea after f5 to go to e5 is I think the
strongest but even if we consider
something like King f1 rook c 2 rupee
one queen e 2 I will block with the King
and then play with my rooks around the
round upon he always needs one look to
protect the pawn it cannot be protected
by upon and therefore i'm playing with
extra forces against his weaknesses so i
guess that this is really a very good
position for me yeah i have the computer
here stockfish running in the background
and it climbs to up almost a plus one
score after a while okay 0.8 now it is
much better for white he probably needs
to play it differently i'm not sure
about twin a three maybe he should just
keep the Queen's on very tricky or queen
a 326 actually trying to get in rikki
six queen e seven or something or try to
to to play on the Kings side with them
yeah something that this is not really
working between a three Quincy 126 I
take you three
honey the spawn really seems to be more
reliability than strength okay thanks
for watching